[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'invité de 8h30 comme
chaque samedi sur france info avec
myriam encaoua bonjour bonjour
journaliste politique à la chaîne
parlementaire c'est vous marier à 20 qui
posait la première questions à notre
invité
françois-xavier bellamy tête de liste
les républicains aux élections
européennes
bonjour françois-xavier bellamy un jour
jeudi soir c'était votre premier grand
débat avec les autres têtes de liste sur
les services publics et à lire les
commentaires et bien vous êtes resté un
peu en retrait pas toujours pu glace et
souvent sage est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
trop gentil dans cette campagne
d'abord je crois que au fond nous avons
besoin d'un débat sur l'europe et d'un
débat approfondi et je n'ai jamais pensé
que c'était à coups de slogans ou de
punch line qu'on pouvait faire éclairé
qu'on pouvait éclairer le discernement
des français au moment où ils vont
devoir faire un choix très important
pour l'avenir de l'europe
j'espère que ce débat a pu contribuer à
les intéresser à l'europe mais au fond
nous en sortons tous je crois avec un
sentiment de frustration parce que plus
que la confrontation que j'ai trouvé
finalement assez respectueuse
c'est d'abord la brièveté des
interventions qui empêchait de
développer c'est vrai un propos qui
puisse prendre en compte la complexité
des problèmes sur le fait que vous soyez
un petit peu novice à ce niveau là de
campagne de candidature et sur un format
comme cette émission raphaël glucksmann
à dix s'est confié après il a dit c'est
pas trop mon truc
s et des gens lui sont tombés dessus en
disant bah si c'est pas son truc il faut
pas qu'il soit tête de liste est ce que
vous vous seriez compatissant envers ce
qu'il a avoué
moi j'ai trouvé très très touchant de la
sincérité de ramener le luxe manjé pas
du tout le sentiment qu'elle était le
signe d'un manque d'efficacité politique
au contraire je pense qu'on a intérêt à
remettre un peu de langage naturel dans
ses arènes politiques à se remettre à
parler comme le font les vrais gens à ne
pas dissimuler à ne pas s'entourer
d'artifice lors ce qui est vrai c'est
que nous avons choisi d'être là et donc
aucun d'entre nous ne peut faire
semblant qu'il est là contre son gré il
faut assumer bien sûr la confrontation
d'idées le faire mais il ne connaît pas
dans cette campagne
à quoi est-ce que ça serge crois que les
français sont épuisés et la cds des
confrontations inutiles
ce qui compte c'est la fumée nos
désaccords d assumer franchement je
regrette que certaines lignes politiques
manquent parfois de clarté quant à mme
loiseau ne nous dit
par exemple dans quel groupe elle va
siéger c'est un vrai problème de fond
parce que il faut que les français
puissent savoir à qui ils confient leur
vote à qui ils confient leur voix mais
c'est pas en cognant ou c'est pas en
s'attaquant qu'on pourra servir cette
clarté alors vous dites sur le fond
qu'il y a une place pour une troisième
voie dans cette campagne entre la
république en marche pour européenne et
le rassemblement national anti européen
mais sur le fond on a encore du mal à
savoir laquelle emmanuel macron c'est le
progressisme c'est le mot qu'il s'est
choisi marine le pen le populisme elle
ne récuse pas le mot et vous c'est quoi
l'enfance est très simple dans cette
question européenne je crois que notre
famille politique incarne non pas une
troisième voie mais la voix dont les
français ont besoin
je le vois tous les jours sur le terrain
d'un côté vous avez des gens qui disent
l'europe ne marche pas mais persévérant
dans le déni continuons d'aller comme le
dit le président de la république
toujours plus vite toujours plus loin
sans qu'on nous dise exactement vers où
nous nous avançons
ce qui compte c'est de faire plus de
cette europe qui ne marche plus de
l'autre côté vous avez des gens qui
diront parce que l'europe ne marche pas
et on les a beaucoup entendu lors de ce
débat il faut défaire l'europe et nous
serons plus forts tout seul nous nous
croyons ni l'un ni l'autre comme je
crois une immense majorité de français
nous croyons que l'europe est nécessaire
nous croyons que nous serons plus forts
par une alliance de nos démocraties qui
nous permettra de relever ensemble les
grands défis de notre avenir
mais nous croyons que pour que l'europe
puisse refaire la preuve de son
efficacité
il faut changer en profondeur la manière
dont elle se construit même l'oiseau
vient avec son bilan elle est courageuse
de venir avec son bilan et c'est très
bien qu'elle le défendent elle nous dit
que ça y est la france est de retour en
europe et que les choses vont bien que
les choses sont déjà amélioré que chacun
constate si cette direction que l'europe
a prise lui convient nous nous croyons
qu'il faut réorienter en profondeur la
manière dont se déploie le projet
européen sur les thèmes de campagne il
ya une forme de paradoxe qui d'ailleurs
s'est matérialisé l'ours de ce débat de
jeudi c'est que notre collègue yaël
goosz notre confrère avant au début de
l'émission il dit que l'immigration
n'est pas vraiment un thème qui remonte
souvent quand on interroge les français
or ça a quand même occupé une bonne
partie du début de l'émission et il
s'est passé des choses depuis sur cette
thématique écouter ce qu'a dit hier le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner à propos du travail des ong qui
porte secours aux migrants méditerranée
les ong jouent un rôle essentiel pour
apporter une aide aux migrants cela ne
fait aucun
toutefois en méditerranée centrale on a
observé de façon tout à fait documenté
je vous le dis une réelle collusion à
certains moments entre les trafiquants
de migrants et certaines ong
on a observé que certains navires de ng
était ainsi en contact téléphonique
direct avec des passeurs qui faciliter
le départ des migrants depuis les côtes
libyennes dans des conditions
effroyables souvent au péril de leur vie
les ong dans ce cas là ont pu se faire
complice des passeurs christophe
castaner vous êtes d'accord avec ces
propos c'est pas maladroit 2 comme ça
accuser les ong d'être complice des
passeurs d'abord c'est un fait qu'il y a
des contacts entre les ong et les
passeurs c'est un fait qui a été avéré
par frontex qui l agence européenne de
lutte contre contre l'immigration
illégale et réalise un peu quand même
c'est un c'est un fait mais encore une
fois ce que je crois intéressant dans
cette expérience c'est de voir comment
l'enchaînement des meilleures intentions
conduit effectivement aux pires
catastrophes
on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur le plateau du
grand débat on nous a fait encore la
morale lorsque nous avons dit lorsque
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que nous
avions la responsabilité de maîtriser
nos frontières parce que au fond on
voudrait opposées d'un côté le camp de
l'ouverture de l'accueil et de la
solidarité à ceux qui provoquent les
morts en mer méditerranée
mais c'est exactement l'inversé qui se
produit moi je ne jette la pierre à
personne mais je constate simplement que
nos meilleures intentions produisent les
pires catastrophes et qu'à force
effectivement de vouloir accueillir et
ouvrir à force de faire cette promesse
au continent africain que quand on
arrive en europe on peut s'établir en
europe même de manière illégale
eh bien on entretient ce rêve ce faux
rêve qui fait des morts en mer entre si
françois que certaines ong est ce que
c'est toutes les ong qui ceux qui sont
complices pour reprendre le terme des
passeurs selon en revanche je ne suis
pas le mieux placé je suis pas policier
je suis pas juge je ne peux pas vous
dire ce qui se joue clairement mais ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'avec les
meilleures intentions du monde on
provoque des naufrages parce qu'on fait
croire aux gens qu'on viendra les
secourir en mer et ils partent avec cet
espoir et il y a donc des morts en mer
méditerranée
parce que ces personnes croient qu'elles
vont pouvoir par le fait qu'elle
s'embarque sur des bateaux de fortune
arriver jusqu'en europe si cette
croyance pouvait être
enfin déconstruite si on pouvait avoir
la certitude qu'on ne rentrera en europe
que si on n'y a été légalement autorisé
parce qu'on a droit à l'asile ou parce
qu'on a un titre de séjour
alors il n'y aurait plus de morts en
méditerranée et c'est la proposition que
nous faisons avec les républicains
justement cette campagne européenne
nous voulons que les demandes d'asile se
passe en dehors du territoire je vais
vous proposer une d'un système de double
frontières alors sur la crise migratoire
vous proposez donc un système de double
frontières c'est pas très clair vous
voulez revenir aux frontières nationales
tout en gardant les frontières
extérieures de l'europe donc vous voulez
sortir de schengen non on voudrait
pouvoir maintenir on veut maintenir une
dérogation qui existent actuellement au
code frontière qui régit l'espace
schengen et qui permet aux états de
faire de manière aléatoire ou de manière
ciblée des contrôles à leurs frontières
temps lorsqu'une sont permanentes cette
interrogation cette dérogation aller
temporaire actuellement et elle vaut
pour la crise terroristes nous voulons
la maintenir de manière durable en vue
de permettre une vraie résolution de la
question d'élire atomes étaient des
gardes frontières des postes frontières
par exemple entre la france et
l'allemagne entre tous ses voisins
frontaliers dont ça veut dire que comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui par exemple à
la frontière franco-italienne
aujourd'hui vous avez plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui ont été
refoulés et qui n'ont pas pu rentrer en
france à cause de cette dérogation que
j'évoquais à l'instant il faut que cette
dérogation soit maintenue elle ne
paralyse pas du tout l'espace schengen
elle n'empêche pas la libre circulation
aucun frontalier n'a été empêchée
d'aller travailler d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière à cause cette
dérogation
mais il faut qu'elles soient maintenus
parce qu'encore une fois nous voyons
bien qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
encore capables de défendre ensemble de
manière assez efficace les frontières
extérieures de l'europe est notre
principale proposition c'est de faire ce
travail là parce que contrairement au
rassemblement national ou à monsieur
dupont-aignan
nous ne croyons pas que nous serons plus
forts seuls face aux défis migratoires
le défi migratoire il est devant nous et
ce n'est pas en votant contre
comme l'ont fait les eurodéputées du
rassemblement national tout au long de
ces dernières années ce n'est pas en
votant contre tout ce qui renforce une
politique européenne de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale que nous
parviendrons à être plus forts face à
ces défis font pour les réfugiés pour
les demandeurs d'asile est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec un système de
répartition ce sont les règles
européennes quand viktor orban par
exemple et bien refuse le moindre
demandeurs d'asile en hongrie
est ce que vous dites il a raison
s'asseoir sur les règles européennes
ou pas viktor orban il a refusé cette
politique des quotas de migrants qui
était demandé par les italiens à cause
de la crise de 2015 à la crise de 2015 a
été le moment de la grande impuissance
européenne aujourd'hui nous ne voulons
pas revivre cette impuissance et si nous
faisons bien bas nous pas là dessus je
crois que ce que dit viktor orban
et sur ce point il a raison c'est qu'on
ne peut jamais imposé à un état une
politique migratoire qu'il n'a pas
lui-même choisi pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que les états savent quels
sont leurs capacités d'intégration et
deuxièmement parce que c'est devant
leurs peuples respectifs que les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement sont
responsables démocratiquement et donc on
ne peut pas faire en sorte que la
politique européenne soit seulement une
répartition de migrants d'ailleurs ça ne
fonctionne pas cette politique de quotas
elle est aussi inhumaine parce que les
individus ne sont pas des pions qu'on
déplacerait sur l'espace européen
comme si on pouvait disposer de leur
circulation librement autres thématiques
de campagne l'écologie qui est très à la
mode en ce moment tout le monde s'y met
les républicains sans doute également
parlé de frontières vous vous souhaiter
la création je cite d'une barrière
écologique qui imposerait des quotas
carbone sur les importations est ce là
une forme de protectionnisme
d'abord il faut absolument que nous
puissions redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation est célébrée sur la
question migratoire c'est vrai face au
défi écologique ça n'est pas une mode
c'est un enjeu fondamental pour notre
avenir et c'est vrai pas venu tard comme
mais c'est vrai en version allongée
d'être venu trop tard mais ça n'empêche
pas le fait qu'il faut s'y mettre
maintenant et prendre cette question à
bras le corps la barrière écologique
c'est pour ça ça fait l'unanimité pardon
chez les républicains
oui bien sûr d'urgence environnement
rôle a lancé roger nous défendons c'est
un projet qui a été validé à l'unanimité
par le conseil national qui est le
parlement du parti
cette barrière écologique en est un axe
fort elle consiste à dire que les
produits qui entrent sur le sol européen
doivent payer pour la contribution
carbone qu'ils représentent
lorsqu'on produit un objet on aimait du
carbone aujourd'hui les producteurs
européens les industries européennes
payent une contribution carbone c'est
très bien ça les incite à être vertueuse
dans leur production mais ils font face
à des produits importés qui ne paye pas
cette contribution est donc nous avons
une europe de la double peine qui
entretient une concurrence déloyale qui
pénalise nos emplois et qui
simultanément favorise une production
écologiquement - moins vertueuses et
donc il faut mettre fin évidemment
cette europe de la double peine c'est le
principe de cette contribution carbone
c'est le principe d'une barrière
écologique qui viendra filtré aussi en
imposant nos standards écologiques qui
viendra filtrer les produits qui entrent
sur le sol européen pour éviter là
encore ces distorsions de concurrence
qu'on impose trop souvent par exemple à
nos agriculteurs
allez on passe à l'actualité nationale
l'actualité en france on est samedi des
milliers de gilet jaune devrait se
retrouver dans la rue aujourd'hui
depuis maintenant presque cinq mois
d'ailleurs
avant-hier le conseil constitutionnel a
censuré l'article le plus controversé de
la loi dite anti casseurs celle
permettant au préfet d'interdire
administrativement à des personnes de
manifestions à écouter la réaction de
vincent charmoillaux secrétaire général
du syndicat de la magistrature c'était
jeudi sur france info
c'est quelque chose qui aurait été
extrêmement dangereux dont il a
d'ailleurs pas non plus
l'acquis que ça aurait apolitique assure
relais sur les violences dans les
manifestations qui crée un travail qui
ne crée un président pour les libertés
publiques et heureusement pendant la
régence quel soulagement un devoir ce
risque-là au moins être être la
cartouche vous l'a regretté cette
décision
contrairement à ce monsieur de la vague
du syndicat de la magistrature ce que je
regrette c'est l'impuissance de l'état
qui est paradoxalement organiser et
mener le maquereau ont fait voter cette
loi anticasseurs que la droite avait
proposé ensuite il la soumet au conseil
constitutionnel comme s'il voulait ne
pas l'avoir appliqué d'une certaine
manière ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
comment il se fait qu'on puisse
interdire des hooligans d'entrer dans
des stades alors que des casseurs
multirécidivistes peuvent continuer à
aller dans des manifestations et je
crois que c'est à cette impuissance là
qu'il faut mettre fin d'ici c'est l'état
de droit aussi en france et c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui en est le
garant
bien sûr est que l'état de droit est
respecté quand la liberté de manifester
est directement entravé par ces casseurs
qui viennent paralyser toute
manifestation
moi je crois que les gens qui venaient
pacifiquement manifesté au sein des
gilet jaune pour dire leur révolte
devant une fiscalité qui venaient les
étouffer je crois que cj les jeunes sont
les premières victimes du désordre qui
règne aujourd'hui ce que nous voyons
dans cette période c'est
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de liberté
sans état de droit mais que l'état de
droit suppose la force publique qu'est
ce qu'on fait
les absolument impuissante à mettre fin
à ces désordres et donc c'est la liberté
de manifester qui est aussi en cause
comme met en cause la liberté d'avoir
une activité normale
oui mais ce pouvoir continuer sur le
message est constitutionnel le message
il est peut-être pas forcément peut-être
qu'il faut pas qu'on va dire amalgames
et les casseurs et le fait que par
exemple en région on aurait pu interdire
à des gens comme ça de manifester
pendant un mois c'était le risque en
fait qu'on utilise cette loi de manière
administrative et qu'il y ait forcément
des dérapages ou qu'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier très bien maintenant
le conseil constitutionnel s'est
prononcé
c'est entendu maintenant ce que nous
attendons du gouvernement et je rejoins
sur ce point guillaume larrivé qui est
un très fin juriste qui est une des
figures de notre mouvement
guillaume larrivé a demandé que soient
réécrites au plus tôt la nouvelle
version de cet article 3 de manière à
permettre encore une fois de mettre fin
à cette impuissance de l'état il ne faut
pas que des casseurs multi récidivistes
puissent venir parasiter les
manifestations et si nous ne le faisons
pas permettez moi de vous le dire c'est
la liberté de manifester qui sera
durablement en cause dans notre pays
cette nouvelle forme de deux de
mobilisation cynique nihiliste qui veut
seulement détruire et dévastée elle
mettra fin à l'état de droit dans notre
pays et le conseil constitutionnel ne
suffira pas à remédier à cela une autre
idée qui vient de votre famille
politique c'est de suspendre le rsa pour
les casseurs qu'ils perçoivent
là encore il peut y avoir un problème de
constitutionnalité
vous auriez été député vous auriez signé
cette proposition de loi les
républicains
ce qui est certain c'est qu'encore une
fois il faut mettre fin à l'impunité des
casseurs et je crois que la première
manière d'y mettre fin c'est d'y mettre
fin par une réponse pénale qui soit
vraiment à la hauteur
aujourd'hui on les aide aussi à
l'occason c'est une bonne idée c'est pas
allé sans fin c'est une idée qui peut
être explorées mais le principal le
principal c'est de faire en sorte que
ceux qui viennent casser pour casser
soit effectivement sanctionnés
je crois qu'effectivement il ya quelque
chose de scandaleux pour ceux qui dans
notre pays voit des gens dont le métier
semble être de casser et qui tous les
samedis des vastes l'économie de notre
pays dans le fait de voir que ces gens
là vivent aux crochets de 2 du rsa c'est
vrai que c'est un problème majeur
mais le premier problème c'est qu'il
faudrait que ceux qui effectivement se
livrent à ces dévastations soit
effectivement condamné est effectivement
un gars rsa n'est que trop peu le cas
aujourd'hui jean paul ii
voix vous connaissez qui est au
commissaire en charge de la réforme des
retraites aurait menacé de démissionner
cette semaine si certains ministres
continue à estimer que l'âge de départ
légal à 62 ans pouvait évoluer
c'est un scénario sur la table en tout
cas il a été évoqué par gérald darmanin
sur rtl cette semaine on écoute la
question se pose aux français si vous
souhaitez qu'on réintègre les retraites
si vous souhaitez que l'on finance la
dépendance si vous souhaitez peut-être
demain encore plus de baisses d'impôts
il n'y a pas beaucoup de solutions soit
on creuse de déficits et la dette
ça nous y refusons en tout cas ce sera
pas avec ce gouvernement actuel puisque
la date d'aujourd'hui c'est les impôts
de demain
ou alors on travaille plus longtemps
dans les ministres l'action et et des
comptes publics chez nos confrères de
rtl françois vous avez xavier bellamy
est ce que on peut sortir du grand débat
en disant aux français voilà on vous a
écouté ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
travailler plus longtemps mais d'abord
on est en train de vivre une séquence
totalement surréaliste pardonnez moi de
le dire mais sur ce sujet là on a on à
monsieur darmanin qui vient à la radio
en disant qu est ce que les français
veulent et ce qu'ils veulent partir plus
tard et ce qu'ils veulent rester à l'âge
actuel
au fond on attend d'un gouvernement
d'abord qu'il nous dise quel est son cap
et je crois que on vient de vivre trois
semaines complètement improbable dans
lequel tous les jours on a une annonce
divergentes je comprends monsieur
delevoye honnêtement d'être dans une
situation nerveuse compliqué mais je
crois que les français sont aujourd'hui
à bout de nerfs on n'a pas droit de
jouer avec les français sur un sujet
aussi fondamental que le gouvernement
nous dise quel est son cap et comment il
entend s'y prendre et qu'on ait enfin
des décisions claires c'est ce qu'on
attend de lui
parce que si vous si vous si vous me
permettez une seconde d'attention sur ce
point quand on crée l'incertitude sur un
sujet aussi important que les retraites
qui est le travail que les gens ont fait
toute leur vie et la manière dont ils
vont pouvoir vivre les années qui leur
est devant eux ont produit une héparine
de réserve
on incite les français à ne pas
consommer à mettre de l'argent de côté
c'est très mauvais pour l'économie
et c'est aussi une forme d'un dignité
qui est fait lorsque on joue avec cette
question si fondamental on en n'a pas le
droit à vivre dans cette paisible
sur le fond beaucoup de ténors dans
votre famille politique sont pour le
recul de l'âge légal
on a déjà des chiffres afin d d d d âge
incertain ces 62 63 et même certains
c'est 65
vous êtes d'accord il faut le recul et
et combien jusqu'à quand une chose est
certaine moi je ne suis pas je suis
candidat à l'élection européenne et la
question des retraites mais pas n'est
pas n'est pas le sujet fondamental de
cette élection mais cela étant dit
mettons au moins sur un point nous avons
le devoir d'assurer l'équilibré de notre
régime de retraite et nous avons le
devoir et monsieur darmanin qui nous
parle de baisser encore les impôts doit
faire sourire beaucoup de français parce
que ça n'a pas encore vraiment commencé
nous avons le devoir de rééquilibrer les
comptes de l'état et ça ne se fera pas
sans que nous puissions faire des choix
courageux sur la question des retraites
ce qui est absolument incroyable c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on nous propose une
réforme compliquée une réforme de grande
ampleur dans le postulat de base est la
question qu elle ne fera pas un seul
euro d'économie
vous allez devoir de faire des économies
sur le régime des retraites pour pouvoir
garantir à nos aînés demain une retraite
qui soit digne ce que nous finançons
comme ce que nous proposons au moins ça
devrait faire consensus c'est d'abord de
faire l'unité des régimes de retraite
entre le public et le privé est de
supprimer les régimes spéciaux de
retraite et déjà se seraient 5 milliards
d'euros d'économies on devrait déjà tous
se mettre au moins autour de ce postulat
d'accord et ça me paraît être une
évidence
et puis après que le gouvernement encore
une fois qui est en responsabilité nous
dise ce qu'il compte faire
mais c'est vraiment un enjeu fondamental
et je crois qu'on n'a pas le droit
aujourd'hui sans fergie l'école tient il
ya une info qu'on a développé ce matin
sur france info
les élèves de primaire sont depuis enfin
sur les dix années entre 2007 et 2017 le
niveau je vais reprendre ça dans l'ordre
le niveau en maths des élèves de
primaire à a baissé en france comme
c'est quelque chose qui a été amorcée il
ya 30 ans est pas imputable à emmanuel
macron du coup ce n'est pas imputable à
aimer le maquereau ont bien sûr ma g mon
premier engagement je suis professeur de
philosophie mon premier engagement a été
comme enseignant pour dire que la baisse
du niveau de notre école était la plus
grande menace qui pèse sur notre avenir
je le prends voulions c'est par ce
constat il vous inquiète
ah bah y'a rien à nu
ans et c'est d'ailleurs une enquête team
ce qui avait été publié à deux ans déjà
sur le niveau des élèves en
mathématiques démontré que nous étions
les derniers de cette enquête sur la
question de l'enseignement des
mathématiques sur tous les savoirs
fondamentaux
notre système scolaire a profondément
régressé et nous avons besoin de prendre
au sérieux ce défi parce que si nous ne
savons pas transmettre aux générations
qui nous suivent notre culture les
éléments fondamentaux du savoir qui leur
permettront de construire notre avenir
alors nos sociétés et durablement menacé
dans sa capacité de construire
évidemment son dynamisme économique mais
aussi sa vie démocratique et son unité
tout simplement âgés beaucoup il faut
prendre au sérieux sur les savoirs
fondamentaux
c'est l'expression qu'utilise très
souvent jean michel blanquer le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale il ya
cette réforme du bac qui inquiète avec
ce tronc commun mais il ya des des
filières avec notamment des
mathématiques ça va dans le bon sens ou
au contraire vous vous comprenez les
craintes du corps enseignant
moi je comprends les craintes du corps
enseignant j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
jean michel blanquer
il a fait des choses qui sont très
positives il a contribué justement en
parler du primaire à rééquilibrer
l'investissement de l'état vers le
primaire et je crois que c'était
nécessaire mais je te le dis comme je le
pense je ne comprends pas cette réforme
du lycée je ne la comprends pas elle me
paraît être le décalque de la réforme du
collège contre laquelle je me suis
engagé au cours des dernières années
avec exactement les mêmes principes
moins d'heures de cours une
spécialisation plus précoce qui me
correspond pas à ceux dont les élèves
ont besoin ni non plus à ce dont a
besoin notre système économique de
demain le monde économique qui se
dessine c'est un monde profondément
nouveau et qui appellera des élèves bien
formés de manière généraliste avec une
vraie culture générale et aujourd'hui on
propose d'aller vers une plus grande
spécialisation
malheureusement je crois qu'il ya là des
économies à courte vue pour le coup qui
sont faites trop rapidement cette
réforme qui n'a pas été concerté qui n'a
pas été bien préparés qu'ils suscitent
beaucoup d'inquiétudes de la part des
parents je crois qu'il serait sage de
pouvoir temporisé ou en tous les cas
engager un vrai dialogue sur cette
question fondamentale quand même si les
français sont moins bons en maths
qu'avant on n'a plus le temps ce monde a
fait les comptes ces îles 18h58 donc on
va devoir s'arrêter là merci merci à
vous
une pénalisation d'être passés à france
info merci mr diamant kawa merci m on se
retrouve samedi prochain